and Ludlow Christian that he is and I
think perhaps only Captain Marvel could
have slowed you down tonight you did
though make NBA history you've scored
more through your first five games than
any other undrafted player where does
that level of confidence come from UConn
somehow I work well definitely uh
my faith the dudes Christ and just hard
work and letting it out no clock your
team avoided a Hawks comeback in the
fourth quarter
it kept their first unit limited all
night long where is this heat team
finding the advantage so early and often
this season just getting system triggers
we got a lot of guys that can play mate
and we share the ball and we be good on
offense coming next your team is hosting
James Harden Russell Westbrook and the
Rockets what type of test will that be
there's definitely a test defensively
they got a lot of guys that go score as
well James Harden but we lock in and get
it together
well done Kendrick thank you guys
Kendrick young played high school at
Simeon in Chicago with Jabari Parker
they won four straight high school
championships heavily recruited went to
Illinois left their encounter rocky
terms went to Oakland went undrafted
he's played a couple years in the G
League signed on the final day of the
season last year by Miami to a two-year
contract and he has blossomed with a
career-high 28 points tonight